[موسيقى]
الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل 13 ضابطا
وجنديا في معارك غزه خلال يوم واحد ليرتفع
عدد قتلا الى
158 منذ بدء العمليه
البريه كتائب القسام تؤكد قتلها 12 جنبيا
اسرائيليا في معارك وكمائن نصبتها في جحر
الديك وخان يونس ومناطق متفرقه من القطاع
جالنت وانس يتفقدان قوات الجيش في القطاع
ويؤكدان ان الحرب ستستمر حتى تحقيق
الاهداف
نم كتائب القسام تعلن فقدان الاتصال
بمجموعه مسؤوله عن خمسه اسرى اسرائيليين
وترجح مقتل الاسرى الخمسه بينهم ثلاثه
وجهوا مؤخرا رساله لحكومه نتنياهو
والرقابه العسكريه الاسرائيليه تحضر على
وسائل الاعلام تناول قضايا تتعلق بالحرب
في مقدمتها ملف المحتجزين في قطاع غزه
ومفاوضات الافراج والعمليات العسكريه في
[موسيقى]
غزه عشرات الشهداء والجرحى في قصف
اسرائيلي على خانيونس والمنطقه الوسطى
وجبال
البلد قوات الاحتلال تقتحم مدرسه الرافع
بجباليا وتعتقل عددا من وتلقي قنابل
دخانيه وفوسفور المفوض الاممي لشؤون
اللاجئين يقول ان وقف اطلاق النار السبيل
الوحيد لوقف ازهاق الارواح وايصال
المساعدات واطلاق
الاسرع الله عليك رسالتي لرب العالمين
لانه منشدنا كثير الدول العربيه ما حد مش
في حدا
مستجيب في الضفه الغربيه قوات الاحتلال
تقتحم مدنا وبلدات عده بالضفه وتنفذ حمله
واعتقالات اشتباكات عنيفه بين مقاومين
فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال في تول كرما
والجزيره ترصد تهجير اسرائيل لتجمعات
يقطنها اكثر من الف فلسطيني في الاغوار
منذ الس